liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
heute vor 77 jahren endete europa der
zweite weltkrieg das schweigen der
waffen am 8 mai 1945 sich eine
friedhofsruhe über den gräbern von mehr
als 60 millionen frauen männern und
kindern
millionen sind von ihnen auf den
schlachtfeldern gefallen millionen sind
in ihren städten und dörfern in
konzentrations- oder vernichtungslagern
ermordet worden
deutsche haben dieses
menschheitsverbrechen folgt
umso schmerzhafter ist es mitzuerleben
wie heute 77 jahre nach dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs erneut rohe gewalt
das recht bricht mitten in europa wie
russlands armee in der ukraine männer
frauen und kinder umbringt städte in
schutt und asche legt ja selbst
flüchtende angreift
für mich ist dies ein achter mai wie
kein anderer
deshalb wende ich mich heute an sie
wir können nicht an das ende des zweiten
weltkriegs in europa erinnern ohne der
tatsache ins auge zu sehen es herrscht
wieder krieg in europa russland hat
diesen krieg entfesselt
einst kämpften russen und ukrainer
gemeinsam unter grössten opfern um
deutschlands mörderischen
nationalsozialismus niederzuringen
deutschland hat sich damals schuldig
gemacht an beiden nationen der
russischen wie der ukrainischen mit
beiden streben wir seit jahrzehnten nach
aussöhnung
nun jedoch will russlands präsident
putin die ukraine unterwerfen ihre
kultur und ihre identität vernichten
präsident putin setzt seinen
barbarischen angriffskrieg sogar mit dem
kampf gegen den nationalsozialismus
gleich
das ist geschichtsfälschung und empfahl
dies klar auszusprechen bistum pflicht
doch damit ist es nicht getan
es war der militärische sieg der
alliierten
der nationalsozialistischen diktatur in
deutschland ein ende setzte
der deutsche sind dafür bis heute
dankbar
daher konnte der damalige
bundespräsident richard von weizsäcker
1985 vom 8 mai als tag der befreiung
sprechen
aus der katastrophalen geschichte
unseres landes zwischen 1933 und 1945
haben wir eine zentrale lehre gezogen
sie lautet nie wieder
nie wieder krieg nie wieder völkermord
nie wieder gewaltherrschaft
und doch ist es wieder passiert krieg in
europa darauf hat der ukrainische
präsident selensky heute hingewiesen
in der gegenwärtigen lage kann dies nur
bedeuten wir verteidigen recht und
freiheit an der seite der angegriffenen
wir unterstützen die ukraine im kampf
gegen den aggressor
das nicht zu tun ist sie zu kapitulieren
vor blanker gewalt und den aggressor zu
bestärkt
wir helfen damit die gewalt ein ende
finden kann
daher haben wir in den vergangenen tagen
und wochen weit reichen und schwierige
entscheidungen getroffen zügig und
entschlossen durchdacht und abgewogen
wir haben nie dagewesene sanktionen
gegen die russische wirtschaft und die
russische führung verhängt um putin von
seinem kriegs kurs abzubringen
mit offenen armen haben wir
hunderttausende ukrainerin ukraine
aufgenommen
hunderttausende die vor der gewalt in
ihrer heimat bei uns zuflucht finden
hilfsorganisationen leisten erste
unterstützung schulen und kitas richten
willkommens klassen ein bürgerinnen und
bürger neben geflüchtete bei sich zu
hause auf für diese enorme
hilfsbereitschaft überall in unserem
land danke ich ihnen von herzen
und wir haben erstmals überhaupt in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik waffen in
ein solches kriegsgebiet geschickt
in großem umfang und immer sorgfältig
abwägen auch schweres gerät das setzen
wir fort
ich kann mir gut vorstellen wie sehr
diese entscheidung viele von ihnen
bewegen schließlich geht es buchstäblich
um krieg und frieden
um unsere historische verantwortung und
maximale solidarität mit der
angegriffenen ukraine um die sicherheit
unseres landes und unseres bündnisses
diese ziele miteinander in einklang zu
bringen diese aufgabe stellen wir uns
tag für tag
dass wir als land über fragen solcher
tragweite intensiv miteinander
diskutieren
das gut und legitim zur demokratie
gehört auch solche kontroversen respekt
und gegenseitiger achtung zu führen
darauf hat der bundespräsident in seiner
rede heute morgen zu recht hingewiesen
aus vielen äußerungen die ich dieser
tage höhere spricht ernste sorge sorge
auch davor dass sich der krieg ausweitet
dass der frieden auch bei uns in gefahr
geraten könnte
es wäre falsch das einfach abzutun
solche sorgen müssen ausgesprochen
werden können
gleichzeitig gilt
angst darf uns nicht lähmen
ich habe ihm geschildert was wir tun um
recht und freiheit zu verteidigen in der
ukraine und in ganz europa das ist sehr
viel
und zugleich tun wir nicht einfach alles
was der eine oder die andere gerade
fordert denn ich habe in meinem amtseid
geschworen schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
dazu zählt unser land und unsere
verbündeten vor gefahren zu schützen
vier klare grundsätze folgen daraus für
die politik
erstens keine deutschen alleingänge
was immer wir tun stimmen wir auf das
engste mit unseren bündnispartnern ab in
europa und jenseits des atlantiks
zweitens bei allem was wir tun achten
wir darauf unsere eigene
verteidigungsfähigkeit zu erhalten
und wir haben entschieden die bundeswehr
deutlich besser auszustatten damit sie
uns auch in zukunft verteidigen kann
drittens
unternehmen nichts was uns und unseren
partnern mehr schadet als russland und
viertens wir werden keine entscheidungen
treffen die die nato kriegspartei werden
lässt dabei bleibt es
dass es keinen weltkrieg mehr geben soll
erst recht keinen zwischen
nuklearmächten auch das ist eine lehre
des 8
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger ich
kann ihnen heute noch nicht sagen wann
und auf welche weise russlands grausamer
krieg gegen die ukraine enden wird
klar ist aber einen russischen diktat
frieden soll es nicht geben denn werden
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht
akzeptieren und wir auch nicht
selten standen wir mit unseren freunden
und partnern so geschlossen und geeint
da wie heute ich bin zutiefst überzeugt
putin wird den krieg nicht gewinnen die
ukraine wird bestehen freiheit und
sicherheit werden siegen sowie freiheit
und sicherheit vor 77 jahren über
unfreiheit gewalt und diktatur
triumphiert haben
dazu nach kräften beizutragen das
bedeutet heute nie wieder
darin liegt das vermächtnis des 8